頑張りあーやばいスパーいい
[音楽]
はつや姉はいというわけで今日
カタロ語ろう
a 棟まあ4月からバサ気分は中野に帰っちゃうんで
まあ本当に
youtube はじめてから
タイマーなくずっといたのがあなただけなんだん
マジで
戸籍に入っ
なんか変なチャンネル作ってなぜだけミックス者沿ったんだっけ
そうへというかそんなんか俺が入学した時点で
もうすでに初めてたば1か月弱ぐらいだったんだよ登録者が何人ぐらいだけ仙人とか
エッセン自分にメーカーが入ってない
本当に多分500600くらいだところは
の時にんか背中まあ大学ではさあ
知ってる人が入ってる方も大学の人しか登録してないんじゃないだって言われ意味で
名前出てるだけだけど
でまぁなんか当時 mixi の時代だったからそれで友達になって
でなんか俺が
たまたま見てたから面白いですねみたいなメッセージおよそ
なんかにはまず日か来たようなイメージがあったんだよねそうそうこっちがお
じゃあ何中に入れたらヤン役立つぞ a ではれその時に
うわーこれめっちゃ大学生っぽいと思ったろサティも知れずねー
汗かこう youtube というものがあるじゃないに出てきて
まあこれが大学生活
そう雅紀くんと出る本当にあるショップからなんですよ
翌2年
はじめ参加に年になんだよねで俺が1年
てもそっから u 2始めてから
ずっと本当に
唯一
一緒に行ってくれた
方なんですよねもう6年6年でもやばいよ小学一人仕上がっちゃうね仕上げレベル4
バクチャーがってるよ
すごいよねそうだからちょっとねぇ
掃除機結構混ぜて話ですよう
マジでから成果なくん
ん
[音楽]
はちょっとまあいろいろ
年
いろんな理由があってその道を選んだと思うんですけど
[音楽]
まさか快く
応援していきたいなって僕はをプレセ皆さんもしてそうしてほしいなっていうところで
おります
そんな不仲説が出たよね会うーん
始め盗撮全員猿みたいなやっほー
そういうのが2ちゃんで見たんですけど本当そういうわけじゃないし
ん
釣り泊まりに来て遊んでねね
次あってるんだ
とてなかったらここまで6年やってくれてねマジでで本当にう
共同かほんとあのぺちゃくちゃ喋るだけなんであのラジオがてらに聞いてください
よかったら
[音楽]
どうでした6年
学連もでも改めて考えるそんなやってたんだなっていうのが一番あれ
いや多分ねーうまかったとこ簡単だ6人が入ってきたのは距離感なんだ
オイラが思うん
そんな毎日あったわけじゃなかったん
すごい期間が開いてあったこともあったし
頑張ってるの3日間あったときもあったけど
そうなんかね距離感が凄い良かったん
[音楽]
すごいよかったよりかなりやりやすだったしね普通に動画撮ってたりしても
なんかなんとなくお互いのがわかってるから
素直に文句言ってくれるのがすごいありがたった2
[音楽]
言ったいい意味でねいいねブーブー不仲説だからですか
なんか電車の国
デスクなんかねえ
高
始めるを塗っていいですか生んだ校塾にねなんか気にかけられすぎるとまぁ
こっちも気にかけちゃう俺うん
長谷川先パッドちゃんと言ってくれるうん
悪いとかったバーみたいな嫌な時はバーみたいな
それがすごいやりやすかったのっていう
[音楽]
結構ストレートまんでしょだった
そうだねー
はリプさんとマジでよかったなっていう
言わせてますねまあ回りくどい言い方を歳の
ん助けに
はぁ
4日
萌え度グッツ
[音楽]
フリウリなっ引っ込むリー
んでも普通に
プライベートで眠剤に種族ね
いいけどまず普通に点シュートパスそうまぁねぇ
1年目だしね
[音楽]
竹そうだなぁ
ん分
うーんことも株があると思うけど
に遊びに行きたいな子のようにやっぱ6年住んでた明けからさ確かにね
6エースんけれども方2んだよねねぇ
静岡いいところでした
あったかいしてねー
やっぱ長野だしんだ山田氏
甘いも気候が全然違うじゃ助け+けど過ごしやすいように食いあるけど
ニンテンダメできるとそっとあーそろそろさああなたねと結構寂しいよねまじ寂しい
なぁ稼動がー
のそうだけど普通に同額全然関係な視点となりました
ん
っていうのがあれからね
今生育するあそうだね温泉行ったりご飯行ったりとこの二君に行っ
polling も it する
おりに来て
やって一時期数も集
7ぐらいで今週に入ってください
たぶんねほんと去年ねいつだっけ2年前からね
[音楽]
ん
2016年館
に骨や行き過ぎると分
[音楽]
ああああっ
根据聞くにて多分
[音楽]
ブーバー今日ってにょぷじゃあぬぅあああああ
なんでかわかる
飲んで
あれはね終電が年後からみんな電車ですよね
電車生活だからそれでまでに数ショップ覚えた方が何か良いみたいであんまり来ない
ものねそのそうそう
ただし増加はもう車生活っていうか車社会だから
静岡のカードショップ2時とか5時までやってるですよパスはどこ
そうなっちゃうと20まで行っちゃったりしてるから
22こうやってね床とした後にシャーラーメいいですか
それモーラー目ですか言ったじゃないが親友のこっきりならミスペットなくて
見事取っちゃったところでますねぇー
なんか俺らそういうのもいけないことを
お嫁さんがこのへ引っ越してきたとき最初
マイティー
2番手 wi-fi からで動画藤太郎当たるしてそれから温泉入って
ドトール行って帰ってくるからもうマインツだったんだよそうだったら
鳥栖徹底だってはじめた時初めて会った時19でしょ
10月ですやーだよバック未成年だったんだよ3戦でだった姉はラファロ
やらせる
結構キツイんだな結構
re
[音楽]
変化しましたね色々ねー
最初の頃になりたい放題であってもちょっとかこのアホ脚太りというかこの動画見よ
預かっついてこれまさにだよ
乳から弁部にです塗装かけるどっ9
そこで旋律って言う
背を考えでたやばくない最初っからじゃんだよ私でねこの動画が旋律って誰がついてる
から
こっからたの選別のねって言うああこれが旋律でからだったのがこれ初めて知ったんだ
けども
マジでだーそっかーぺっを願ってるぞ
6年目の真実なんだけどっわっっ
犬が
[音楽]
国連だ
初女さんもの黒いよ黒いほんとそこだよね一番すごい
じゃあこの時ほどでか肌肌着やじゃなくてさ北陸に住んでたからあまりわけじゃなくて
あーやー&クリックって曇りと香りもするぞ
貯蔵家に聞くらあった方に阿部て気持ちよすぎてずっと沿っていたらすぎて5着
これね結構ねやり始めてから
一番再選衝撃受けたのがん
あれ布団性格ああ
やってたらそんなのも
あれはわっムースとやばいんだなっていうのはれてないだあああ
[音楽]
そうあのね意外とねし通院のねー
あんまり連続じゃないんだよねその最初はたぶんすごい少なかった
実はネオン by masaki 普通がねぇ
たまに出るっていう
今もだもんねーナンデルっていうスタイルが続いてるんですけどこっからもいいです
入っちゃってるもののね yes
結構
何か感じた切り寂しかったためしかった待ってる側としてはすげー
長く感じた半年でもねないね患者そうそう
作った
相馬先はね本当
のフクアリなんですよ
登立少ないじゃんまあ見がちな方でうん
うまくん
粘りと女友だちので聞いたこともないでしょ萎え萎え萎えないなぁ本当に
その状況で
なぜくっつき合うと思う奴って本当に珍しくて
割とすごいですよけっこうすごいよ
[音楽]
32なくないんだって
96年間見てきデー
食べますより長い人いないんだよ今もちゃんと帰って関係があるって言う人が
な山
スインユーザ親友ジャポ推演算
秒オーバーこもってちょっと中母なんかあれだと我らじゃあまた
う
すげーなー
そう考えると
[音楽]
ちょっとマジな話をするとでねほんともなぜを話していい感じやばすぎたらなんか
学校になんかなりそうだったからちょっと気になったしますでしょん
ちょっとこの見送る側としての
月の悩みとしては
[音楽]
ちょっと学校で大丈夫なのかなって u ターン心配が結構
もうなって日常生活でいろいろ
出てそうまあまあまあまあ行為どこ行ってもさーん
何か切ってくれ c
昔なってこうなんか
いろんなさん行くぞいこれマンはそうだねー
それが学校となると
[音楽]
海辺なのかなって思っちゃいますねええうん
でも逆に
ですそれから多分
マイナスっていうとあれなんだけど
ただまぁそのちょっとみんなが気にせれてんだと思うけどなんかポジティブな見方を
すると
多分その
この新しい仕事ジャンヌユーチューバーってそれこそ俺ゆったり始めたとき
ユーチューバーなんてことがなかったじゃなかったッ
金ももらえなかったのそうそうそうだからその感覚なかったで離れただけ
それが今職業としてやってる人達が結構いるわけだし
っていうのを考えてはなんかやっぱ先生になった時に伊方ば学校の先生たちはあんまり
まだ気付いてないけどやっぱキャリア教育とか
なんか今後ほとんどの仕事がさ
ai にカーっていう中でユーチューバーって多分へ ai ちゃう無理な仕事なんだ
よ
無理だねなぜだよじゃあもう飾るユーチューバーの中に
人がいるかもしれないベストすーっ多分多分結構無理だと思いこれよりこと p
いやいややっぱりクソつまんだいうことになるから
ペナ思うとなんか実は今後重要な
ことは直接教えるかどうか分からないけどできるかもしれないし
確かにねなんか人ので曇り的なところで
そうそうそのたからなんかこうやってなんかさぁそれこそ俺らが
大学生になってユーチューバー初めて
た当時ユーチューバーとも思ってなかったけど今やユーチューバーになって
っていうこの変化にとってやっぱ学校とかも
先生も変わらなきゃいけない子はからっていう意味ではなんか自分ではプラスとして
捉えている
経験的なそうそうかまあなかなか他に経験する先生てないからないと思うよ
う技汽笛の心配はあるなんかそっちの精いっぱいとこっちの心配が全校
ああ
絵はもう始めた張山寝ると言いながらさもう
ほぼ寸レギュラーず今のまま
まぁ俺がそうだね言うとなんかや勝ちファンに叩かれそういや何も全く成り立たない
からねこのちょっとは本当に
なんか心配というか気になるのが
次誰がドッキリ引っかかるんだろうへいへい長いちょっと嫌う
うんっ
本当に全部ガチだったじゃんドッキリが or の岩瀬下
俺たちのドッキリにやらせは何からねほんとやらせが1回はなくて
たまにコメントってかさーリプとかでくるじゃんかやらせるじゃないんだなっていうか
でも本当に通えなかったから
[音楽]
んですかねそうこれ今後だ言って受けられるんだって行った時にはなくその中で公安
サッサだ察することあって妄想入ったりそのままつっコースてそうだからなんかこう
いう話って言われてから1回もないだからなんと私が言ってからそうだから are
you do
4日
いやでも客にあの子だけな反応とかって一番面白いと思う
えっ
意識せないけれどれその純粋なんだ俺えっ
くっ
これはね衣
いやそう月
線チャンネルやんざんまたラスク
それも100人を遺族のとしまさくんもいなくなったから
[音楽]
まあ結構その二人が支えられたとかめちゃくちゃだったわけん
誰か言ってくれて成り立ってるとかあったけど
一緒に出演する人が
良いだけなく時に
俺多分無理だなっ
って思って詳述
[音楽]
1人度とレッド本撮りたいとたくさんあるからそこは全然いいんだけど
ドッキリ仕掛けれると言いたいなぁと思いますよ
なんか
仕掛ける人はいるんだよあの遊戯王を始めてから友達増えるんですよ
本ない面があったでもいう行が繋いでくれいいゲームプレイ的です結構
結構勝ち目に正木くらい
友達がいなかった数字というかああ
大学3年
留学から帰ってきた時本当そうだよねそうだよね宅にも沿っなんかすぐに何か学園
変わっちゃってから注いてくれて1年を置いてかれて
ぼっちの時期があって
で正木トレーダーで雪を始めてん
それでめっちゃ友達が振って
duras の関係が深まって
游行以上のう
関係が気付いて
[音楽]
親しい友達が多い理由だといいも
そこ発生してるでしょ別役合わせですかソ
孤独せしないな
ねぇ友達はいるんですよ
信頼できるよ買って本当によかったよ
コミュニケーション能力がないか
くっカードを通じて誘い系ですよねそう
だからなんか遊戯王もいろんな意見があるんだって
ゾーンだアプリでカードゲームってあるところああ
だから遊芸もん
電子化というかデータ化した方がいいんじゃないかっていうチェーンが生み出すんだ
けどそれぞれ人とのコミュニケーションがは長くてべきとかそう
そうなるとカードゲームの醍醐味って何だろうっていう話戻った時に
やっぱ人と話すツールっていうか誰もいなみたいな
裸足靴部体制の会話が苦手な人とかも助けにね
そういうのを通じて初めてその
同じような発音の人に歌うことができた可能
普通に何か
カードゲームってすごい
いいなって思います
何度動画んだってになります
bouvet に行かなきゃいいし母まあね趣味全般にいえることでそうそう見て一つ
だから
がそれがたまたまカードゲームカードが伸びてます
カードゲームだっていろんな人と知り合いて
それで友達が増えたからうーん
マサキと匠以外にもドッキリ失敬でそのトモズいる理由よりも
ただその子たちもいろいろアレッサ
大きくなりすぎちゃったかなぁ
動画に出すのはちょっと
弾けちゃってくうん
[音楽]
強いぞ
なんだよね
多分だから再今の湯通話って結構
ゆ中バー
っていう言葉の前かられてるからあんまりそんななんか
ビスクかを考えずにていうか楽しく本当にやろう蜜会みたいな感じだってからあれだ
けど
ここから始めるってなんて結構ねっ
ネットで開かれるこの話ともうボコボコすよ本当に
コメント欄で僕をこの時もあるそれからボコボコネットで母校お兄ちゃんでボコボコ
あれ全然本当に口で二里ね
あるしイベントで入って避けられるって言うんですよあれじゃあ俺はあれからね自分
ズンってあるからよってもそれってさー
杉原されてい
よくないと思うんだよ
[音楽]
なんかみんなスルーしてるけど
よくないと思うけどうん
匿名でも
よくないと思う多分匿名だからなんだよね
そうバレないもんねそうそう誰かにこうしねとか言っても笹
傷つかないわけじゃんだからちょくちょくだったら言えないとダメっつって言うはじめ
してねーとか言えない前だけだだけどまあまあ学名だからね自分のことが誰かも分かっ
られないでしょ
やずるいなぁ
新食べないか向こうからそれと多分こう俺られ
が
あったことなければ本当に何か
アニメのキャラと一緒なわけでもただの誰もお調子者に見えるだろうず数分尾山ず
ネットの使い方をさ
チャン島せた方がいいと思うんだよ
炎上している人が言うことでて来られたああ
ん少なくても
犯罪には触れないでちゃんとちゃんとあーやってねえけど
方法に溢れるようにねそうなに過去の犯罪だけをしない
っていうことをやってきてるから
ただ本当に
ネットで
[ __ ]とか殺すだけで犯罪になっちゃうからさんそうだね
もっとかしたいところがありますよ
ここはやっぱりユーチューバーとしてできることがあっ
ああああああ
けどねもう言われて構っちゃうとも理由だと思ってるクソすごいらもうただする
苦しくない
なかったことにしている自分の中で自分の変化でセットしてるなんてもうもう大丈夫し
た結構
パーフェクトででも者市がすごい今回は家や部屋止めやる全然コメントなんでしょね
正木いらなくねみたいな
始めだけ出ればいいじゃねーっていうかあるし全然あったですよ
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーバーその
ん
別だけど
成合がんばりまーまーまーえ
好きじゃないかなホント皆さん
ネットで
悪口だけは言わない方がいいですよ
なってあれだよもしそれでさあ訴えられてさ
警察にこういるな
逆探知サルサ ip はられてさあ中バレたらさ
ありますよ
歳なんですよ性がんだよ
[音楽]
ん
強い時代なんでネットの使い方だけは本当によく考えて使ってみてくださいそう
啓発動画も犬派7分二
悪口言っても満たされないからね自分が
一時的なねそうそうスッキリする鬼没抜けだからそれから暴力と空を切ったを以前マジ
でうん
ニューヨーク言うのかねそれぞれないはずしようとしたときちんチャンネルのことが
麻生線チャンネルね
それでもう今までずっと一緒に出てきてくれたたくみと雅紀が痛くなって
どうしようと思ったとき
[音楽]
そいつらを出そうと思ったわけね
ちょっとうな
だから多分です
ちなみんどう思います線チャンネルですねメンバーを
あーでもなんか逆に俺はそれ
割と楽しみでん
なんか俺とか匠さんもそうだし
なんかいままでそのお礼とか匠さんしかできないこと多分やってたとは思うのこの
チャンネルの中でねそうだ
でもなんか客に新チャンネルのその新メンバー
って
タイプは全然違うじゃあみんな
いろいろ違うねそうそうだからなんか逆に本当に違う動画が見れるんだなっていう
楽しみがある
助けんうん
微妙に違ううん
[音楽]
どうなるんだろう
ねぇー
ラーいいんじゃないをゼロそうだなとか間もすごい楽しみなんだけど
[音楽]
楽しみではあるけど強いにまあね
怖いそれを加えそうだよね新しく本当にゼロから度かねそれを
[音楽]
あそこには先あってくれたんだってよもやベジそんな
そんなあれだうーんそのあれだ送り出したいんで俺ううん
うん移動しなって思う時がは誰だなそういう
どっこ頃いくだしますけど
そういう話もしたもんで他馬にんどうすることは通っていう結構
今年はしたよな橋だしたすごいしたと思う
[音楽]
急いでも俺はそう思ってくれてもすごい嬉しいし
じゃあ本当正木ての始めちゃってそうだよなとかよみうりランドのさ
イベントの一番最後とかを
本当に嬉しかったから俺は本当に
先がいないとダメだよ出て来ない理由がじゃないけどね
も多分なしだとマンないもーん海神いる我々やでしょまあでもある大丈夫かいい年です
それぞれえっ本当に100倍もせろよって言う
[音楽]
まじちゃ
面白いのがあるんだよねたナッツが想像が引っ越すかな
そうね冷蔵庫せんだけど2割が4月に使ったで区今2においてヲタだっつに来る柄
グッズかん
yeah
ん
これはでも
パッチも嬉しい
ほぼそいつらもいるからなんとか言っていきますよ
逆に自分がいないから今度逆にもう一ファンとして
選びから身内道引っ張ら8始めるかさっそく
4前条たらたって多い全然も助けに来るルーサー
援助しないでねまぁ頑張ってみる
その後ねーうちの母ちゃんが正木をすごい評価してるんだよ
嘘かなぁ
まずで表しているこのお母様に違うっ
あの子は
それで結構嬉しいですしうーん打つのが先ほど革新につくタイトな買ってからなんか
取れない
b 見てでやっぱりた毒舌っていうかソすごい
俺らに対して黒酢は理想全部 us しゃる
なんか俺とは俺に対してもなんかこう
そしてなさいされなければねするぞ
早くねーよこのターンや別に今だから話すんですけどあのう
去年ちょっと塩蔵してたんですかっ変え人間関係はぁっ
あれを切る
だいぶ前から
なんと女性関係だけ気をつけなさいよねー
カートの話せ最後に毎回毎回言われてて a
お祝いごとにモンスターを着ていたから
核心をつくんではなくとってからマッカイさあ
未来移しているような未来位置するちなみにあのいいすか切り裂き映司くんが命という
だって女子たじゃないですか
あれもあれがを切り1か月前にちょっとあの子
最近大丈夫便を言ってて
山まずでこいこいつじゃねえっマジですごい
ても釣ったねほんとに全部未来映してるからすごい雪ですよ
多分ねぇいいんじゃない
いけば汚れやばもう最後の最後でいるではないけど
もう行ってくださいいうかもしれねぇねぇ
切ないねないこれは言っても何度も
ああああああああ
もう誰に対してもを持つ手を
楽しかっ
楽曲がたくさんあるし
大変だった曲は高さ放ちでいっ
例えば俺多分あてぃん
あの風船が大変だったが彼が浮くんか
風船が河原で風船服のも左前打
まずやつねー
あれですかね結構きつくじゃなかったネタピカねそうですそうです川の中州みたいな
とこ行くぞそう
正木話になってるみたいだワークはそして水めっちゃ冷たい時やってるよ
無事カードは追った本と思うんだけど色々無茶ぶりをしてしまった縁があったなと思う
けど漏れ結構
始めてる
黒だなって思ったのは熊大全紙にクソなぁ
本当に徹夜だったじゃん
なんだを盛ってるんだろう
夜
こっちでってさいってさ
本当に朝日が出るまでやったぜ上げていっ
ムースで本当に強くて
でなくこっち it 版じゃあやってから極限なのに最後でそれなんかもう
ものと立てれしたら
うんなぜマジかよだろうっていう
いや俺はでも空ば倒せると思ったわけよ
このから本気で揉んでるよねそれがちな顔だと思うん a
各国あれが初めてうわぁ
大変だなぁと思ったいっ
[音楽]
ん
朝わかったねいなかったしいっ
4を
は大変だったん
[音楽]
結構大變態変な結構あって置きますよ
いや結構大変なことしてるよ
大変と
すごいよかったなあが半々なのがダーツの旅なんだよわぁレイバーがすごかったなーと
かまだやってねえの一回ってクラやってねば
これか
混ぜ徹夜だって誰もまず靴が売っ運転がきつかったプロそそう
えってかフックに減るまず j
制裁がいいでした3時間後ぐらいにここでてるからだッ
たずの旅したくねぇ見た言い出して
でっ
まあアレさんの弟とらちょうど来てたんでね
で3人で
往復なってるッ
ありそう願ってるんですぐ
地図買いに行ってそれか行き帰りの運転がすごい大変だったけど向こういっていうの
撮影用すっごい楽しいかな確かにあのあれだねついてからの海とかすごいよ買って理想
で村上の綺麗な事本当あるちょいが良かった良かった
すごい綺麗だったのを覚えているでもみんな極限だってから
英語映像を撮ったと思ったら弟か600あるであろうまず
[笑い]
歌じゃねーぞえっ
[音楽]
これが取れで行った器楽長いえーよね
弟が録画してなくてよくわかんねえ物になってしまいまして
うーんでもあれはでも楽しかったすごい
旅行気分もあったしうんよこすねもう願う
沿ってがまあでないじゃんまずとインドアだよねそうぞ
でも食べる打てば皆早産結構
確かに確かに花粉可逆月
すごくていいんじゃないと絶対出ないという本当に
引っ込んでて a
そうだからさ
や湖を悪く言うわけじゃないんですけど東京行くの
家にいたいんですよ東京作ったりないじゃなくて家にいたいんですよ
うふー感じ dan
ともコンビニかラーメン屋さんにしかない花花日ジャンプの発明ジャンプだ
カード版に遊ぶ v ジャンプの発売に誰よりも先によしでもいいけど
いやー
本当に家が家だってというか
動きたくないもんでヒルスそうだよね
割と一嫌いだよねー
スローモーション嫌いと言う母ってか初めての人が熱
あると自分の
何か作りたくなってるん
そんな彼に雅紀がねえ
ほぼノンストレスでいてくれてたからさほぼって言うとまた御幣頑張れるんだけど
スターでねちふれんだから
メーラーすごい6年間7に木で幸せだってるっていう
えっですっ
4選んだけどね良かったよね最後に2人
出てきたらイベントが
[音楽]
よかったで曲あったまんだけど一緒に本当にそれこそあれもすごい近かったと思うと
一緒に
アトラクションに乗ってるというか俺はせこい z 煌成功年かけています
えっ
[音楽]
ですこれが
ね
[音楽]
6年間ね
えええっ
プロ6年間だよ
ねえええ
[音楽]
ねえ f
r ん
ねぇ
ちょっと
狂ってるんだっ
[音楽]
入ってないんですよ
してるんだっ
黒いツライっ
[音楽]
一つしかない青山悩んだよ
まずに救われたででも
jaf まぞんだ
グッカメイカせれて絵草紙た時も座
動画行きてくるくざぞ
[音楽]
総合でドッキリとかさ
やっぱそうだねだどけもいやいやいいんだからやってくれるえっ
あっ
[音楽]
ウズれたぶー
4日
初めてズっていうのが
マサキが止まりじゃないと
2付かなかったと思ってるん
ran
[音楽]
san
ペン通学やじゃないんじゃないんですよ第たことないんで人生で絶なぜ
マジーニョなお姉さん系んだからさぁ
留学してたから
q で3年までですよえっ
はやふるだった
黄金世代がたかったと思ってフォーク不在であるけど
[音楽]
夜中だぜ
行く内で別だよねぞうけど
本当に俺も関数でから本当に本当に結構迷惑しかかけてねーてが早いや
ほんとに一緒に行ってないとできない経験がほとんどだったし
楽しいっ
勝った本当に
本当にっ
今思うとその6年間
そんな長かったんだなみたい確かにねぇ
なんかな買って今だってね早かったねー
ちょっとのシコっ
[音楽]
よかったねー a もう終わっちゃうぞ
第二章が大事じゃないねうんまだわからないかね何がを切らないからね今後は
手首をまさにその例であって
普通に社会に出たけど
色々あって戻ってきてずっと離れちゃったけど
ん
何が起きるかわからないとかそう今
運転してそういうもんですよ戻ってくるってこと
いやーたんですけどうんそうだねそれは
駒に今の自分はこう思ってるって言うのもあるし
1年後の自分とか5年後の自分がどう思っているか幅たその時になってみないとわかん
ないですね
まさにそれ
でも溝もこの6年間は本当にすごい楽しかったし
大切な6年間だったなと思っている
[音楽]
ブービーイコンとにさてもらってほんとに一緒に出来て良かったなーってもう三
ウォッチャーミクシィはあーヌー
特価って肩ホットン受けられるぞマジであえて言うなら相棒だったよ
なあ相棒だってっていうとしてるよね合いそうだよ
リボでや言ってね
テレ朝からドラマのほうが距離に俺ら2人こいつ止め絵って思うんか立っ
いやもう次ではてらそれでも丸くなってああ
いやいやいやダメじゃないですかそんなことないですよ
だから先に千葉が吹っ飛んだよね結構吹っ飛んだよえっ
ただ昨日なんかあれだよ
あぶりーさんをチーズ15が食ったかという
やってかおかしいで本当に本で緑水なタウン山釣り頭の何かがあるよ多分本当にあるよ
[音楽]
一年尾鷲のかもしれないんだよつ試合ってさぁ15皿全部の若干
なくなればぶりだって美味しいんだよおおお
美味しいとかそういう問題じゃないかってだけですかたよいいがすごいで
絶対店員さん弾いてる
a
夏投打の時語品番中でお願いしますすっ
母さんもうちょっと聞かしてくださいそれをさあ
入り的にだからこそにばワールドと思いますよ
6年間0
ここで見てるわけだからね
上でよくこのう
終わりたいだけど
f
ブルー
本当に
濃かったなぁ9年間が凍った
おっ
[音楽]
うんうーん
プ
楽しかった俺と撮影しててめっちゃ楽しかったよ
うれしい
ロシアの南下行き詰まった時に将生と撮影せいだと思う
うーん
なるほどねうん
指を巣立つ作っ
うれしい
なんか俺も
その一緒に撮っ
って楽しいし
上がったのを見て
[音楽]
なんか面白くし続けてるの良い店のもうトイレしますねちょっと編集二次リーグして
くださいね
年かね宣材写真みたいなパッヘルベル処するじゃあ
4寸もうを開いて追いながら面白いし
なんかね俺は結構嬉しかったのがなんかその
なんか俺がまあなんかいいえバーとかとご飯行った時に結構みんな
すごい
始めたを尊敬しつってマジでそれはまあやる団と歌うよ
よそれは俺はすごい嬉しかった
なんかこう
一緒に行ってて
一緒に行ってるしすごい楽しいけどなんか光一ファンでもあるしてすごい好きだって
から動画が
それからそれを褒めてもらえるねすごいですも悪いだったからすごい
すごい
なんか他の人が始めたの褒めてるのを聞くとすごい嬉しかったし
ってか今後も一ファンとしてすごい楽しみな
ファン the ない身内でもう何があったら相談するか
頑張って
抽選に応募してはじめの音イベント行くかもしれない
国連列ができるあっはぁ頑張りゃ
やることはお互い変わったけど
[音楽]
がんばれていっ
甘酢を動画でレイヤーにきついね学校に怒られちゃうんねこれていく
頑張ってね
4月以降は1歳
ロバに出ること
ないけどまぁ2
絶対元気にやってるんで
やまないれずるー
[音楽]
闇様になったら
めっちゃ食ってると
[笑い]
f
だけどねーだろその後あった時に気づかれない
[音楽]
なぜこれが割とになると思う辛いなぁサイ g ね
6年間って考えると
でもやばい
だめだよねつあって太宰ゾロくらい買えよキュッ曲本当にねまあいろいろ
メンバーもいたけど本当6年間ズって売ったのが
6年間本当にこの二人はずっと一緒だったローン
上で長すぎる男性がねぇ
6消費性があの時昇一が中学になってますよ
が受かってる
がったおっ
そしてよくここまでこれた目ほんとな年そうだからさあ no
どうやったら鮮肉すってば
全然人超すてもさー
南海運勢人数子エラーみたいなの
ずっと話してだりとかして多分これ本当にイ
し今見てる人はあんま知らないと思うけど
夢んだろうって頑張ってた方って歌ペック
ね融通はけっこ側も難しいでいい
ピッコロ最初の頃は大変な思う
[音楽]
いた中でこうやっていかねえ種類
それが今や日本一だよねー
仕掛けにサビからそうだけどえっ
[音楽]
10です全然者を出してねーじゃん
おっん
これはもう日本ちゃんによるが重いから行かれて
そこを付ける様に頑張りたいなっていうああううううううああああ
無理ではうちにきついつらい俺には伝わらないんだっっ
頑張っていたもう急に向かって
[音楽]
っていうタイプじゃねぇん
逆に燃える文字そうじゃないと思えないんだなぁ
山崎さんで改めて
言わせてもらいますけど
6で行くありがとうございましたえっうんっ
こちらがされがございましたんでねん
[音楽]
ran
言ったろいっ
[音楽]
ん
me
冷凍ですねっ
[音楽]
5回複成じゃねーぞ
スレ
[音楽]
レオン種だが貸してくれなかった
6年間かー
まぁでもその結果日本一だからどうぞ未だちょっぱーてぃーん
源氏でねだ何よねー
よかったぜねぇ俺なんですが日本一だよ
とりあえずあ
本当に岩岳これっ
もう明日わかんないからさーだからねぇすぐ枯れてはわかんないけどねぇ
というわけ
本当に
割とガチでたぶん僕の随時家の中で一番の親友だったと思います
思いますじゃない梅雨ですねっ
頑張ってね姉だっても
動画ないと思うんですけど飛ばしてサイバーだよ見るとダメだからな
振り返ってもうよかったら見てくださいねほんとね
ふっだけど正樹さんもフォルデ
飛び出すと思うんですけど
引き続き雅紀も弾みさその甥の方よろしくお願いしまーすなぜ舞う
a のアディアアアアアア ano ざーだっ
[音楽]